[Applause]
brendan fraser in tears amid his
renaissance
is exciting
the actor cried tears of joy as he
received a six-minute standing ovation
at the venice film festival
you could say fans are getting a blast
from the past as the actor who burst
onto the scene in the 90s steps back
into the spotlight with the lead role in
the whale dream come true brandon was
visibly moved and clearly humbled by the
audience's reaction
[Music]
one famous fan applauding from afar
dwayne johnson brendan's mummy returns
co-star he shared his well wishes and
thanks to brendan after the clip went
viral tweeting quote man this makes me
so happy to see this beautiful ovation
for brendan he supported me coming into
his mummy returns franchise for my first
ever role which kicked off my hollywood
career rooting for all your success
brother
for brendan's latest role he makes an
epic transformation he's completely
unrecognizable playing a 600 pound man
his character is a writing instructor
struggling to reconnect with his teenage
daughter played by stranger things sadie
sink
it always chimes four times
for exactly but this isn't the first
time brendan's been vulnerable about his
comeback i think i might be sick a
little anxious
oh no i mean it's gonna be fun
yeah last year during a virtual meet and
greet with fans the actor got a little
teary over this sweet moment you've got
this you've got this just
just know that
the internet is so behind you we're so
supportive there are so many people out
there who love you and we're rooting for
you and we can't wait to see what you do
next
shucks man
no doubt brendan is feeling the love but
a quick word for millennials maybe hold
back a bit if you see brendan out and
about very often um
millennials young young people to me now
that i'm stampeding towards middle age
and wearing cowboy hats press events
approach me and say
oh i love your movies
i loved you in georgia's jungle i was
four years old
[Music]
[Music]